the situation with donald trump's legal
team is becoming more
of a uh soap opera than anything i
recall
seeing over the last 25 years relating
so directly to the president of the
united states
donald trump's former lawyer
and almost special counsel sydney powell
is now claiming
she's been banned from the white house
um
i don't know whether to start with the
new part or
let's start with the new part and and
then we'll go backwards and i'll catch
you up on everything so listen to this
uh sydney powell telling fox news
she's been banned from the white house
and from speaking to trump check this
out
this is during an interview on fox news
where anchor john roberts is
interviewing
republican strategist karl rove is
general flynn's attorney sydney powell
who suggested after a meeting on friday
night she's been banned from the white
house in a statement to fox news saying
i've been blocked
by white house counsel and others from
seeing or speaking to the president
since i raised the public formal
findings and even more evidence of
foreign interference
from iran and china i'm told that she
still has the ability to call the
president she's not on any kind of
do not admit list at the white house but
i do know
that there are many people in senior
positions at the white house
who would prefer that ms powell and
others stay away from
okay so now that we've seen that you
really have to understand
the backstory to comprehend the level of
absurdity that that is going on here so
shortly after the election donald trump
tweeted about sidney powell as one of
the lawyers representing him
uh he tweeted on november 14th rudy
giuliani
joseph de genova victoria tensing sydney
powell
and jenna ellis a truly great team added
to our lawyers and representatives very
clear trump says sydney powell's part of
my team
great shortly after that sydney powell
joined donald trump's lawyer rudy
giuliani and jenna ellis and others
at this bizarre basement press
conference where they made all sorts of
very unusual claims none of them based
in fact and this is
the major press conference at which
sydney powell
started making the radical claims about
hugo chavez antifa and george soros were
part of a plan to steal the election for
trump and this was
so crazy that it got the trump campaign
to put out a statement
basically distancing from and and sort
of like firing sydney powell
saying sydney powell is practicing law
on her own
she is not a member of the trump legal
team she is also not a lawyer for the
president
in his personal capacity so it seemed
sydney powell
was out if she was ever in which trump
said she was
she was then out per the trump campaign
until
last friday she shows up at the oval
office and she's the one talking to
trump about
maybe martial law maybe we seize voting
machines and all sorts of other
wacky ideas as well as reportedly
telling others in the room who were
saying you know
sir that's illegal saying you guys are
quitters
that made instant headlines because
number one
it's nuts and number two supposedly
trump
was distanced from sydney powell so how
is she in the oval office and how is she
potentially going to be made special
counsel and then now this
which is sydney powell says she's been
banned from the white house
and from speaking to trump and now
they're all going after her here's
another clip of karl rove during his uh
same interview with fox news just
bashing sydney powell
this pal has peddled theories that have
little basis in fact
uh the idea that hugo chavez from the
grave
was somehow involved in stealing this
year's election and that
i mean she was poured out in a courtroom
recently where all of her expert
witnesses which
you know one of them was so uh highly
prized that he had to have a code name
and couldn't be revealed that he was a
she sold him as a highly you know expert
military intelligence analyst
turned out to be a mid-level computer
programmer from dallas
who couldn't even pass the entrance
exams for the 305th
intelligence brigade in intelligence
school
he couldn't even pass the exams and he
was her high level advocate
she had another expert who couldn't tell
the difference between
election precincts and townships in
minnesota and michigan
and claimed at 151 percent turnout in
wayne county michigan when any idiot
with access to google and the and the
county election returns could have seen
that the turnout was 51 percent
not 151 i mean what she has done
to sort of uh you know throw mud on the
president
through her addicts is unbelievable the
president has been so ill-served by this
crowd
and and she's chief among them what i
absolutely love about this
is that karl rove is absolutely right
in his criticism of sydney powell but
the things that rudy giuliani
and jenna ellis have been peddling are
only
marginally less crazy than what sydney
powell has been saying
karl rove and john roberts now are
framing this as whoa
sydney powell's nuts but actually
they're all nuts
and their work is totally worthless
and going nowhere but it's funny
and it's sad and it's a bizarre soap
opera that seems never to end
but it actually will end relatively soon
it'll it'll be much better for the
country now there's lots of
i've been seeing so many different legal
commentators and lawyers
saying the behavior of rudy giuliani
sydney powell and uh jenna ellis before
a variety of courts over the last month
month and a half
really does warrant uh complaints to bar
associations
and that these are the types of actions
that should should
really get somebody disbarred um i don't
i don't think it's likely that that will
happen but understand that
these figures have crossed over from
being
like i guess what we would call legal
lawyers into being
almost like cult activist type figures
where even if they were to be disbarred
for the things that they've been doing
at this point they can launch off into
being
tv lawyers for all sorts of right-wing
groups or
radical organizations or reactionary
movements so
it's almost irrelevant at this point
although i don't think it's a
uh it goes beyond the facts to say how
how could these people even really still
hold
uh bar association licenses but that
that's probably more of a story for post
inauguration
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away and get rid of the
vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get
20 off when you use the coupon code
pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical